ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález como todos
los años el segundo martes de febrero es
celebrado el día del internet seguro
esta fecha sirve para hacer balance
sobre el uso de esta herramienta que
conectó al mundo entero pero sobre todo
promueve su uso seguro particularmente
entre los menores de edad y los jóvenes
que hacen un uso digamos extenso de las
tecnologías digitales lo que se busca
con esto es tener un internet pues mucho
mejor que permita tener al mundo
conectado con acceso pero con total
seguridad con respeto que sea usado de
manera responsable y que potencie sus
diferentes usos también que sea crítico
digamos de una manera saludable y que
sobre todo sigue siendo una herramienta
creativa en esta versión que es la
decimonovena en esta conmemoración el
lema mundial es juntos por un mejor
internet pero dimensionemos entonces el
alcance del uso del internet en las
redes sociales y en la actualidad para
que veamos las cifras actualizadas en
cuanto al uso de internet según las
cifras del 2021 el 60 por ciento de la
población mundial es usuaria de internet
el 55 por ciento de la población mundial
usar redes sociales y el 67,1 por ciento
de la población mundial son usuarios
únicos de teléfonos móviles el 76 por
ciento de las conexiones a internet son
a través de teléfonos inteligentes o
smartphones
el incremento en el uso de internet
varía a diario todos los días se
incrementa cada vez son más las personas
que hacen uso de esta red global en su
día a día poco a poco muy lentamente el
internet llega cada vez a más lugares
remotos en diferentes rincones del
planeta pero si hay algo en lo que el
uso de internet destaca es en el uso de
las redes sociales veamos entonces
cuáles son las más usadas actualmente de
acuerdo a cifras del 2021 el top 5 de
las redes sociales más usadas en el
mundo lo encabeza facebook con dos
puntos 74 mil millones de usuarios
activos le sigue youtube con dos mil 291
millones de usuarios activos en tercer
lugar está whatsapp que es de mensajería
instantánea con dos mil millones de
usuarios activos facebook messenger ha
alcanzado 1.3 mil millones de usuarios
activos y cierra el top 5 en la red
social instagram que tiene 1.3 mil
millones de usuarios activos les aclaro
que estamos hablando de usuarios activos
esto no es igual a personas usuarios
activos pueden ser perfiles
profesionales de empresas grupos
organizaciones instituciones personales
y pues por supuesto personas naturales
como usted o como yo
esta fecha nos lleva a reflexionar sobre
qué tan segura está el internet hoy en
día qué tan seguro es el entorno digital
en el que nos desenvolvemos en donde
todavía hay mucha información sesgada se
fomenta en estereotipos todavía se
discrimina se explota se desvirtúan
derechos y constantemente hay crímenes
acosos y estafas pero así cada vez el
internet sigue siendo más rápido es más
fácil la comunicación es digamos el lado
positivo la interconexión entre las
personas sigue mejorando el acceso a la
información también y los servicios
ofrecidos para nuestra vida diaria cada
vez son mejores en el marco de la
conmemoración del día internacional o el
día del internet seguro del 2022 en
france 24 analizamos la seguridad y el
estado del uso de internet a nivel
global para analizar este tema saludamos
entonces a mari carmen sé que era ella
es abogada cuenta con especializaciones
en ciberseguridad y derechos digitales
es también candidata a magister en
propiedad intelectual ella se encuentra
en la ciudad de montevideo la capital
uruguaya y no muy lejos de allí en
córdoba capital
homónima en argentina está andrés piazza
él es el director del instituto
latinoamericano de desarrollo digital de
américa latina y el caribe ustedes por
supuesto también nuestros televidentes
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar los comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales ya que
estamos hablando de internet pues usemos
las para comunicarnos nos encuentran en
facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24
s y arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestro numeral ese numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos los
comentarios y las preguntas sobre este
tema que nos concierne a todos comienzo
entonces con mari carmen en la ciudad de
montevideo en la capital uruguaya sobre
el uso del internet a lo largo de todos
estos años llevamos 19 años conmemorando
esta fecha en particular para destacar
los logros de internet pero también lo
que está por hacer lo que está en marcha
que se puede destacar de estos 19 años
de conmemoraciones de internet seguro de
un mejor uso de esta herramienta que
podamos destacar y que nos falta por
mejorar
bueno muy buenas tardes muchas gracias
por la invitación
respondiendo al punto totalmente de este
día tan especial es bueno hay un
importante avance una innovación sin
precedentes sobre la tecnología las
plataformas la economía digital que se
ha montado en los últimos 19 años 20 más
inclusive y también bueno los problemas
de relaciones de poder monopolios que se
encuentran justamente en esta lista que
recién compartieron sobre tiene y cómo
estamos utilizando internet finalmente
está concentrado en muy pocas y esto
también ha generado también otro tipo de
problemas dentro de lo que es
ciberseguridad monopolio transparencia
algorítmica y otras entre algunas
preocupaciones que nos encontramos en
este momento es que tenemos una sociedad
que se conecta más de manera más
atragantada obviamente por es la
pandemia sin tener en cuenta de que
estas soluciones tecnológicas que
algunas pueden ser redes sociales otras
mensajerías u otro tipo de plataformas
están pudiendo cumplir con los
estándares de ciberseguridad en algunas
de ellas tienen que ver con las buenas
prácticas de muchos de los países no
tienen buena parte o por lo menos
regulaciones rigurosas sobre temas de
seguridad y esto hace que ponga en
situaciones de riesgo de las personas
que
se conectan a internet y entonces por un
lado acá el mayor rol en la mayor
preocupación tiene que ver tenemos pros
estados deben tener estas regulaciones o
marcos legales rigurosos para obligar a
este sector en este caso en los
intermediarios y empresas en cumplir los
estándares porque es muy importante
entender de que cuando hablamos de
seguridad siempre pensamos que la
seguridad está en el rol de la persona
al consumidor final
como vemos la base de la tecnología todo
el tiempo hay nuevas actualizaciones
sabemos que las personas no
necesariamente tienen que ser expertas
en tecnología uno hace otro tipo de
cosas y simplemente actualizan sus
dispositivos entonces es importante
entender el rol de la seguridad está
justamente en el estado que nos tiene
que garantizar nuestros derechos en eso
virtuales en segundo lugar la
responsabilidad de estos intermediarios
de ofrecernos manera segura el rol más
importante está bueno tenemos un
panorama general a grandes rasgos desde
la opinión de mari carmen allí en la
ciudad de montevideo me conecto ahora
con la andrés piazza en córdoba en
argentina la misma pregunta para el
punto de partida del debate e
impresiones de cómo está el uso de
internet la seguridad la ciberseguridad
después de todos estos años de uso y
sobre todo estos 19 años de
conmemoración del día de internet seguro
momento para hacer balance como ya lo
decía yo al inicio del programa cosas
positivas y negativas andrés
bueno un placer estar aquí también
formar parte de este diálogo es un buen
momento para hacer un balance en
realmente en estos 20 años y en estos 19
20 años se ha logrado una masificación
una extensión del uso de internet se han
democratizado accesos a no solamente a
la información a plataformas sobre todo
de mucho tráfico de vídeos y incrementos
de usuarios sino también servicios que
nos presta el gobierno o también la
libertad de expresión nuestra expresión
es cierto lo que decía mari carmen
respecto de la concentración en algunos
servicios que son de pocas empresas y
que están incluso fuera de los países de
la región en américa latina en sus
servidores en otros países y la
seguridad es un tema central han
aumentado por supuesto con este aumento
de los usos de los buenos usos la
cantidad de tantos estafas como pérdidas
de información como amenazas tanto a la
seguridad de nuestra información como
amenazas físicas o incluso a las
personas de los niños
también de diferentes de nuestra
economía y estas cuestiones
son centrales para las políticas
públicas es importante que los estados
tengan no solamente reglamentaciones
como dice mari carmen sino que
creen estándares para que las empresas
lo cumplan sino que ellos cuando
procesan su información cuando procesan
por ejemplo el gobierno electrónico todo
lo que se puede hacer con nuestros
propios como ciudadanos en internet esa
información esté política es protegida y
al mismo tiempo la privacidad de los
usuarios normativas tanto de seguridad
como de privacidad son un ser importante
es verdad que también es importante
crear capacidades en los usuarios que
nosotros sepamos cómo defendernos pero
esto es un tema más también de políticas
y a nivel general y es lo que lo más
interesante para debatir antes continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda a la
inversa esta versión 19 del día de
internet seguro hace un foco específico
en las necesidades de los derechos de
los más jóvenes que son tal vez los que
más están disfrutando de las capacidades
lo que ofrece internet hoy en día que se
ha hecho en cuanto a este aspecto en las
necesidades en los derechos de los
usuarios más jóvenes desde la parte de
los gobiernos desde la parte de las
escuelas y desde las partes también de
las familias
es uno de los temas más importantes
quizás el más importante de estos temas
primero porque se han creado
se han evidenciado
nuevas formas de daño y de violación de
algunos derechos o incluso de delitos
contra las niñas niños niñas y
adolescentes al mismo tiempo son quienes
más y mejor usan las plataformas pero
ese uso técnico de las plataformas de la
tarde es que los jóvenes conocen en
cuanto a cómo funcionan las herramientas
no va acompañado necesariamente del
criterio de la capacidad de comprender
cuál donde están los peligros ya han
habido esfuerzos tanto de las áreas que
persiguen a los delincuentes como de los
que promueven la de la seguridad o la
que haya creación de conciencia respecto
de los peligros que han trabajado en
conjunto con los estados shan trabaja en
conjunto con las escuelas para mejorar
para comprender que son herramientas que
deben ser usadas que deben ser
incorporadas los procesos de aprendizaje
al esparcimiento pero al mismo tiempo
que que se conozca los riesgos y también
hay algunos peligros de política no
estábamos hablando de cómo se regula de
cómo se plantea esto a nivel macro hay
algunos riesgos porque algunas de las
regulaciones son aquellas que hoy
promueven demasiado un eje demasiado
positivista o promueven un eje que
atente contra la naturaleza de internet
no es la idea digamos justamente romper
un pedazo de cómo funciona internet
porque queremos proteger a los niños
hormiguero y adolescente queremos hacer
todo creo hay que poder hacer todo al
mismo tiempo
mari carmen su opinión en torno a este
tema y le amplio sobre cómo está américa
latina en cuanto a región en este tema
en políticas por parte de los gobiernos
para el uso adecuado la seguridad de
internet por parte de los más jóvenes
siempre creo que estamos en una etapa
incipiente aún no si bien hay políticas
integrales de ciberseguridad actualmente
que deje una mirada específicamente de
niñez y adolescencia es todavía inicial
de que hay un gran esfuerzo desde unicef
para américa latina sobre temas de
cuidado en internet pero también es
importante entender de que estas
soluciones de bienestar deben incluir la
mirada de los niños adolescentes hoy la
tendencia actual de las mayores
plataformas al mayor comercio
electrónico que se ejecutan está en este
espacio de internet son los videojuegos
pero es la industria más grande del
mundo actualmente y aquí no hemos podido
como sociedad aún pensar cómo es el
trabajo de inclusión en estos espacios
de manera más segura hoy se conectan
simplemente a estos tipos de videojuegos
sin una mirada obviamente integral en
temas de educación verdad previa sobre
seguridad por un lado pero por otro lado
también que instancias son necesarias
como para tener y pensar una estructura
o un videojuego con sea más inclusivo
que no sea violento verdad porque
estamos viendo que cuando hablamos de
seguridad siempre pensamos que es
descifrado problemas de contraseñas
problemas o simplemente pequeños
fracasos digitales que tenemos dentro de
internet porque porque fuimos corridos
en una estafa sin embargo también vemos
que estos espacios deben ser más
inclusivos y eso como ya lo decía andrés
es desde una leve obviamente políticas
públicas de cómo incluir como también
bajar esa brecha digital que hoy tenemos
justamente para veces es importante pero
mari carmen en resumen le ha costado
mucho a los gobiernos de américa latina
a decretar políticas para
minimizar estos aspectos que usted
menciona que sean inclusivos que se
evite el acoso o se evite los problemas
de seguridad los gobiernos
latinoamericanos simplemente están
dejando este tema
de lado no es una prioridad como lo ve
usted
yo creo que tienen más cautela no de
tomar como decía andrés una buena una
situación bastante controversial y
compleja sobre la seguridad de los niños
en internet porque la idea de las
regulaciones no son realmente prohibir o
censurar el acceso a ciertas
dispositivos o ciertas aplicaciones sino
de cómo vamos a incluir y aquí el
desafío tiene que ver desde esa mirada
no no todos los países en américa latina
tienen estas políticas y bien dentro de
sus políticas públicas incluye en la
parte de tecnología creo que él ahora la
verdad en el momento de la
implementación simplemente ahora se está
explorando estas nuevas formas de cómo
trabajar está allá en la parte de
educación en américa latina tenemos una
gran deuda obviamente de inclusión lo
que vivimos por el trabajo por lo menos
la educación remota que en américa
latina tuvo muchos problemas no
solamente porque no había políticas de
inclusión sino también la calidad de
internet que llegan a muchos países de
américa latina asia que esto también nos
excluya porque cuando el momento que nos
conectamos nos conectamos creyendo la
tecnología que es un lugar neutral como
un lugar seguro si mientes justamente
esa preocupación entonces hoy en américa
latina' la política de nuestros estados
es realmente en esta primera etapa
conectar a la gente es
la ausencia viéndolo desde la óptica de
los gobiernos de la legislación y el
cuidado que debe haber por parte de las
autoridades para el uso el buen uso de
internet pero qué hay de entonces de los
usuarios que tanto hemos aprendido a
hacer unos buenos cibernautas andrés
todavía tenemos problemas para
desarrollar el potencial máximo que
puede darnos internet sin estar
incurriendo en aspectos negativos nos
falta todavía aprender ser buenos y ver
nautas que piensa usted
efectivamente nos falta pero eso no
significa que tiene que ser una movida
una idea pesimista al contrario digamos
nos falta han crecido mucho los delitos
tanto los delitos que no existían antes
como el grooming por ejemplo o como
las estafas o el ransomware o la pérdida
de información clave pero necesitamos
continuar ampliando nuestras capacidades
y con esa inclusión qué cantidad mi
colega ningún tiempo que venga de la
creación de capacidades de la creación
de no solamente por la vida de las
herramientas está mencionaba el cifrado
mencionaba algunas políticas puntuales
pero las capacidades son de las personas
que estamos en la red que estamos
conectados son importantes y digo si
bien se ha trabajado mucho es cierto que
se ha trabajado mucho todavía falta no
solamente con los nuevos que se están
incorporando permanentemente sino con
los con los usuarios de siempre no
incluso con las propias empresas y los
gobiernos nuestros todavía no han
aprendido de la mejor manera cuidar
nuestra información o vacuidad meeting
quería
y por qué es así que pienso cuando esas
esas fallas han atrás porque sigue
siendo la ciberseguridad una prioridad
llevamos ya muchos años usando internet
pero seguimos presentando los mismos
problemas y acoso discriminación mal uso
de información noticias falsas y tal
parece que no se le puede dar solución a
esto es muy difícil filtrar algunos
contenidos y siguen llegando a los
usuarios y se sigue por ejemplo en el
caso de noticias que estamos aquí en un
canal de noticias en américa latina
siguen llegando contenidos que no son y
los medios quedan en entredicho cuando
han sido diferentes plataformas las que
han distribuido contenidos inapropiados
bueno ese es otro de los grandes temas
de la desinformación es siempre ha
existido pero ahora pone todavía más
como el uso de trípode
a través de alguna plataforma comunicar
y que democratiza la capacidad de
comunicación hay posibilidades de malos
usos hay posibilidades de a su vez
aprovecharse de las reglas las
plataformas de plataformas priorizan el
contenido que genera más interacciones
por lo general es aquel que tiene que
nos causa mayor espanto o mayor sorpresa
es aquel que genera más interacciones y
podemos entonces transmitir información
que no es cierta y hacerla viral muy
rápidamente y al mismo tiempo es un
problema de derechos que hay que
balancear porque la libertad de
expresión de estos usuarios es algo muy
positivo que hemos ganado que también
tenemos que defender y que las
plataformas no dejan de ser empresas
empresas que son intermediarios de una
comunicación general pública quizás y
que tampoco son aquellos que están
llamados a decir que es legal y que no
decir entonces los estados y las
empresas y los usuarios debemos cooperar
para entender cómo mejorar esta parte
que estabas mencionando que es uno de
los grandes problemas
mari carmen quiero profundos un poco más
en este tema sobre la libertad de
expresión de los usuarios pero cómo
hacer balance a lo largo de estos años
de uso de internet no se ha podido hacer
balance entre libertad de expresión y
desinformar y subir contenidos y
publicar contenidos que desinforman y
que hacen parte de las noticias falsas
todavía nos ha costado un poco hacer el
balance y aprovechar la herramienta de
la manera correcta o como lo ve usted
bien en primer lugar como ya decía
andrés este tipo de acciones que pueden
ser estafas en este caso de ejemplos
como desinformación vemos que
efectivamente
son situaciones o patrones que ya lo
había siempre antes de este tipo de
tecnología entonces lo que suele pasar
en innovación es que uno piensa que la
tecnología viene a cambiar todo en
realidad lo que hacemos de reproducir
nuestras formas en este caso de
comunicarnos y que de alguna manera
reproducimos no solamente desinformación
sino práctica en este caso pueden ser de
violencia violencia acoso online
situaciones como de inseguridad a niños
y niñas adolescentes entonces es
importante entender que mucha parte de
estas regulaciones ya se trasladan o se
interpretan en internet hay una
importante importante desafíos nuestro
poder judicial entre sistemas de
justicia tiene reinterpretar obviamente
estas leyes que ya existen en este
espacio cibernético y ahí obviamente
también tiene que ver con lo que tenga
que ver con específicamente
desinformación esta es una agenda que
también ya tiene casi 20 años o
inclusive más de andrés que puede
corregir
ese balance de libertad de expresión y
lo que se considera como desinformación
entre casos pequeños u otra es muy
importante también entender de que no
necesariamente hay malas intenciones
cuando uno genera desinformación hay
veces que hay una interpretación del
propio público que considero
reinterpretó de otra manera entonces acá
el desafío realmente que tiene hasta
antes de lo que es el desarrollo de
internet es la educación y es muy
importante entender que que los estados
no pueden ser paternalista no pueden
ellos no pueden imponer diciendo estos
también esto está mal estos verdaderos
esto es falso hay una zona gris bastante
importante que obviamente la prensa ya
lo tiene hace bastante tiempo de que es
verdad y nunca sabe todos sabemos que no
hay una verdad absoluta entonces en esa
en esa gama es muy importante entender
los límites por sobre todo si vamos a
hacer una reinterpretación sea a partir
de la libertad de expresión del derecho
como base verdad en los derechos humanos
como marco legal básico para
reinterpretar esto y por otro lado una
educación donde no ayudan
hacer una interpretación crítica de
estos pensamientos entonces yo como
persona individual y autónoma puedo
definir si esto es verdad o falso o qué
autonomía yo tengo para decidir claro
que que decisión voy a estar tomando
entonces aquí el desafío realmente
cuando hablamos de esa información es
integrar o sea o no abordarlo de manera
integral por sobre todo desde la
educación y desde la autonomía de la
persona para cerrar esta parte del
programa en torno a lo que nos hace
falta por mejorar y esos aspectos
negativos que llevamos analizando ya
desde hace mucho tiempo sobre el uso de
internet quiero cerrarlo con el
ciberacoso que sigue siendo un problema
grande activo se esconde principalmente
en las en las redes sociales que en
muchos casos permite el anonimato y
suele ser pues el arma preferida de los
acosadores para para hacer de las suyas
y también de los delincuentes justamente
esto sigue siendo un problema muy activo
y ya que estamos hablando de las
necesidades y los derechos de los más
jóvenes cómo manejarlo cómo empezar
a darle a los más jóvenes herramientas
para detectarlo a tiempo
que se ha hecho al respecto porque se
trata de prevenir y no llegar a
escenarios más complejos comienzo con
mari carmen
bien en primer lugar está el tema verdad
después de tema en el sentido de que si
bien son cosas que siempre ocurre fuera
del espacio de internet esto se traslada
a la medida que nos vamos conectando
ante mira masiva y esto no es culpa
realmente de internet y no la
responsabilidad tiene que ver que los
comportamientos hacíamos de manera
offline se trasladan online y estas
situaciones de relaciones de opresión y
de poder obviamente se reproducen
entonces la violencia que ocurría
anteriormente los espacios offline hoy
se traslada verdad y son casi los mismos
comportamientos para acá el desafío
tiene que ver también con el desafío de
esta de
instancias internacionales que siempre
reconocieron que la violencia es muy
difícil de reconocer por parte de las
víctimas nadie quiere reconocerse como
víctima de acoso de violencia digital
de recibir hostigamientos entonces en
este proceso en esta primera etapa lo
que se recomienda es como interiorizarse
de qué tipos de cosas existen en
internet entonces lo pueden hay
muchísimas organizaciones en la región
que ya lo están haciendo entre ellas la
alimentación la cual estoy dirigiendo
que se llama teddy tanto otras
organizaciones también que tienen otra
mirada de género es justamente lo que
hacemos es conversar sobre cómo estos
grupos vulnerables que son niños niñas
adolescentes mujeres en general
campesinas indígenas unidades de gtb
cómo se conectan y cuáles son las
dificultades que tienen estos grupos a
diferencia de otros grupos hegemónicos
qué bueno estar de esta manera generaron
seguras en este espacio entonces la
primera pata para diría es cómo
reconocer que cuál es el tipo de
violencia que se encuentra la otra
reportar en las plataformas hoy al menos
las que más se utilizan en común
comúnmente son
las que reciben y tienen políticas
obviamente de reporte de este tipo de
acoso de violencia como por ejemplo
discusión de imagen no consentidas
verdad tipos de acoso y por otro lado
bueno obligar también a las
instituciones legales a no minimizar
estos hechos lo que está pasando también
en nuestras instancias en américa latina
es que las personas que se encuentran en
esta situación hacen las denuncias y hoy
la policía o el sistema judicial lo está
minimizando y no está reconociendo como
un delito antes para el cierre de este
primer bloque su opinión sobre este tema
del ciberacoso
bueno me apropió de muchas de las
palabras de mi colega entonces aprovecho
para solamente destacar algunas algunos
ejemplos puntuales hoy de puntuales lo
primero es respecto de esta de estas
diferencias de esta distinción es
algunas han sido ya motivos de
regulación hay por ejemplo el grooming
es delito en algunos de nuestros países
por supuesto que la difusión de imágenes
no consentidas cuando son cuando tienen
como víctimas a niñas niñas y
adolescentes es no solamente un delito
sino que a veces es delito la sola
tenencia de estas imágenes en algunos
países de nuestra región y al mismo
tiempo también hay una cooperación muy
fuerte entre los diferentes actores
entre estas plataformas que son las que
son capaces de detectar y las policías
los tribunales la verdad que esta parte
está bastante desarrollada al mismo
tiempo que se está mejorar la creación
de capacidades esto que decía mari
carmen aprendida
e identificar los tipos de violencia yo
comparto que se trata de violencia que
ya existía y al mismo tiempo diría la
red ha permitido amplificar el alcance
de quienes ejercen esta violencia pero
las relaciones de poder o de desigualdad
ya existían es cierto y al mismo tiempo
la red no es el problema entonces muy
importante mencionar esto porque muchas
de las iniciativas que se están viendo y
por lo menos desde el ide de la chs
desde la organización que se trabajó
intentamos mejorar la capacidad de la
toma de decisiones de las políticas
públicas con esto con aprender a
balancear los problemas y no verlos
desde una sola cara por ejemplo en el
caso de niñez de seguridad de la
navegación que la red sea un activo que
se desee proteger al mismo tiempo que se
trate que las personas adentro y la
seguridad que sea claro un objetivo pero
no que la regulación no esté
privilegiando por ejemplo la seguridad
por sobre la existencia de las
herramientas que tanto nos dan es un
balance difícil de conseguir es un
balance difícil de conseguir vamos a
pasar entonces al aspecto positivo lo
bueno que nos ha dejado el uso de
internet a lo largo de estos años y el
balance que se puede hacer y lo que
viene hacia el futuro como ven el mundo
la conexión en la que ya estamos que uno
podría pensar que ya estamos lo
suficientemente conectados a través de
internet
que nos puede brindar más esta red a
nivel global para seguir interactuando
entre los diferentes rincones del
planeta mari carmen
bueno yo activista de conocimiento libre
pero sobre todo siempre podría decir lo
mismo no
creo que esta herramienta nos ha
posibilitado a nuestros nuestros países
especialmente desconectados como la que
generalmente estoy trabajando que es
paraguay y otros países de américa del
sur que bueno es compartir el
conocimiento verdad y que estas
regulaciones que van acompañando el
crecimiento nos puedan ayudar a pensar
en cómo mejor con conectarnos
comunicarnos y compartir por sobre todo
información lo que esto ha acelerado
muchas procesos a la interna en nuestros
barrios en nuestras casas verdad
conversaciones que nunca tuvimos
probablemente ahora lo tenemos gracias
un montón de gente que está compartiendo
pareceres desde perspectivas por ejemplo
derechos humanos y todo lo que tenga que
ver inclusive con herramientas a steven
seguridad que ahora se van masificando
en todas nuestras comunidades nuestros
grupos
lengua está verdad grupos pequeños donde
vamos siempre dando tips para poder
cuidarnos también electrones pacientes
gracias obviamente a la capacidad de
compartir en internet este tipo de
conocimiento andar en su opinión que nos
puede traer esto más adelante en la
interconexión entre todos en el planeta
coincidiendo lo primero coincidiendo con
la colega y al mismo tiempo agregando un
tema central que no nos debemos olvidar
lo tomamos como si existiera pero la
pandemia lo ha evidenciado aún más la
importancia en la universalización del
acceso este es el tema que quizás si
tuviera que elegir uno por ahí es más
importante todavía tenemos países de
nuestra región en américa latina con 90
por ciento de penetración quiere decir
que faltan 10 por ciento son millones de
personas en esos países propios por
ejemplo en el mío y en algunos otros
eso significa todavía millones de
personas hay países que nos llegan al 50
por ciento de acceso y al mismo tiempo
acceso a las herramientas no solamente
significa que con eso alcanza después de
la pandemia de los trabajos y los y los
estudios y la educación y la interacción
con el estado anulado a la red ya no
poder tener acceso de un determinado
nivel que nos está negando la capacidad
de ser ciudadana la capacidad no
solamente de consumir sino de conseguir
trabajo de educarnos y por ejemplo hay
un estándar nuevos hay una nueva idea
en debates internacionales que tienen
que ver con lo que se llama conectividad
significativa en este momento eso diría
que es 4g que hay ha democratizado que
funcione bien en nuestro territorio que
sea también con fibra óptica en las
conexiones fijas y que haya dispositivos
espacios y habilidades todo eso tenemos
que tener el 5 que se viene adelante
también es importante verlo pero con
estas cuatro o cinco cosas nos falta
mucho todavía para que tengamos todas
estas cosas no habilidades dispositivos
4g y fibra en todos los hogares en todas
las escuelas en todos los trabajos es
una importante meta estudiante a pocos
minutos para cerrar el programa pero
andrés menciona algo que me llama la
atención es los estados digitales los
estados ya completamente digitalizados
hay algún ejemplo a nivel mundial que
les sirve de referencia américa latina
de un estado digital que funcione que
esté dando ejemplo de haber alcanzado
este este nicho y haber pasado
prácticamente a la digitalización
completa no sé tal vez me suena un poco
el caso de estonia puede ser que es un
gobierno bastante digital
y que funciona bastante bien pero bueno
estas saben más del tema
el caso de estonia es muy conocido
justamente porque han decidido incluso
extender hasta la ciudadanía de manera
digital aquellos que ni siquiera
recibían y en muchos casos casi todo el
funcionamiento del estado de los
servicios estatales se da con servidores
y procesos en la red es algo que tiene
singulares amenazas también al mismo
tiempo por ejemplo la continuidad del
propio estado de la información es en
ese momento es el estado es todo lo que
implica por ejemplo ejerce la ciudadanía
para nosotros pero para el propio estado
ejerció sus funciones esa seguridad la
seguridad se vuelve todavía más
importante en esos lugares hay veces en
donde demasiada tecnología no debería
ser necesariamente aconsejable por
ejemplo en el voto por ejemplo en
algunas cuestiones que hacen a la
identidad o en algunas cuestiones que
hacen a la privacidad que no todos los
procesos deben ser digitales a por lo
menos en una opinión personal mía no
está claro mari carmen hay algún país
que destaca en américa latina por estos
usos a nivel estatal de las capacidades
digitales de sus ciudadanos un buen
manejo de las redes hay algún país líder
en nuestra región ya para el cierre
y bueno en este sentido va a estar
siempre uruguay ahí arriba como uno de
los países que lideran la lista de
digitalización pero como dice andrés los
procesos obviamente de digitalización
tiene que estar acompañado de países de
democracia sólida no en países donde hoy
te encontramos con muchas debilidades
verdades estructurales problemas
electorales partidos en las
principalmente en democrática en américa
latina y eso hace es que si bien podemos
crear creer que la tecnología digital
instándola vamos a transparentar ciertos
procesos vamos a evitar ciertas
corrupciones probablemente sí pero no va
a erradicar realmente los problemas
estructurales que tenemos no entonces
creo que esa digitalización debe estar
acompañada también de otras cuestiones
pues cuando hablan de ciberseguridad una
necesariamente tenemos tenemos que
cerrar verdad con la idea de que la
ciberseguridad no es la protección de
las estructuras de internet sino la
protección de la persona que está
utilizando el dispositivo no solamente
es una mirada como decía de seguridad de
sus dispositivos en sí sino también
desde salud mental vamos a ir conectando
verdad creo que es importante aprender
los límites también se me acaba el
tiempo mari carmen andrés muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros haber
explicado este tema para la audiencia
france24 un tema tan vasto como la red
misma como el internet mismo ustedes
pueden seguir dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales sigan con france24
[Música]